the US Navy sailor in Naples Italy has
tested positive for coronavirus marking
the first confirmed case among
servicemembers stationed in Europe this
is the virus continues to spread rapidly
worldwide Lucas Tomlinson is live in
Washington with more on that
Lucas John Italy is preparing to lock
down large parts of the country Europe's
most drastic action yet to stop the
spread of coronavirus our colleagues The
Wall Street Journal first reported the
draft decree which would take effect
tomorrow if approved more than 10
million people around Milan would be
affected police and even the army would
enforce the quarantine Italy has nearly
six thousand coronavirus cases more than
230 people have died there the biggest
outbreak outside Asia the u.s. Navy
sailor tested positive in Naples about
five hundred miles away from Milan
Friday the US military announced its
first confirmed case at the headquarters
for US forces in Korea after a South
Korean employee tested positive on the
base this is the seventh coronavirus
case confirmed by the US military in
Korea but so far only one active duty
American soldier out of 28,500 space
there have been infected back home
defense secretary Mark espera says he's
fully confident the Pentagon could
withstand the virus we have a lot of
capabilities in this building our you
know our National Military Command
Center has the capability to go for
weeks at a time if they have to be
locked down inside the building if we if
we have some type of outbreak despite
the rising threat from coronavirus US
Navy warships continue their missions
around the world after leaving Guam the
aircraft carrier Theodore Roosevelt
pulled into Vietnam earlier this week
but warships must now spend at least 14
days at sea following port calls to
quarantine the crew earlier this week on
Capitol Hill the Navy's top Admirals who
asked this key question do you have test
kits no we don't we don't yet but that's
not just a problem for DoD but I think
that I think that we're getting you a
better place in terms of the production
to allow us to be able to distribute
those out to the out to the force at the
Pentagon the head of infectious disease
at Walter Reed Medical Center said
there's no need to panic I think people
should should recognize at the end of
the day this still remains on low risk
infection to not just our service
members but to the American public John
there are now just two confirmed Crono
virus cases in the US military out of
1.3 million men and women in the active
duty forces John worth remembering Lucas
Tomlinson thank you